being a producer a great big story i get
to like travel over the world and meet
all these people and one of the
questions i get asked the most is
where's your cameraman like and i'm like
yeah where did he go like it's me i'm
the cameraman
i think that there's still a bit of an
expectation that people who film and
work as filmmakers are male
[Music]
you don't always see people that look
like me on set behind the camera
producing
[Music]
something people get a bit confused is
that they think cameras are heavy
thus you have to have a lot of strength
thus strength equals man
completely not true
[Music]
you know we pick up gear every day it's
doable the majority of gear is like
ergonomically made for men there's a lot
of ketchup that companies have to do one
of the
moments i'm learning to deal with is the
genuine surprise that i'm going to be
the one behind the camera and the rare
chance that we get two women in the
field it's even more surprising
[Music]
someone might think that i am the pr
person anticipating that someone else
might come around to actually be the
person that is gonna handle the shoot
i've had experiences on set even as a pa
where people are taking things out of my
hand calling me sweetheart telling me
i can do that for you it made me feel
like i wasn't fully capable or i didn't
belong there it's very abnormal to see a
woman as a gaffer it's very abnormal to
see a woman as a dp and i think really
for this to change is their women to be
trained in these technical positions and
start to like change the industry bit by
bit
i've worked in the grip and lighting
department which surprises a lot of
people because it's a lot of really
heavy equipment and then i got into set
design which also requires a lot of
heavy construction and wood paneling and
set building
i see myself as an editor not as a
female editor i think that i'm just
trying to do a good job i feel as though
sometimes employers might see
a male's name on a reel or a resume and
kind of assume that this person might
have
more confidence more experience more
talent
i was working at a job one time where i
found out that
this guy was making twice as much as
what i made and i'd been there longer i
think
just giving women the opportunity to
work
just as equally as men do
can be
a step in the right direction for sure
i've
only seen in an office one other motion
designed woman the whole time i've
been in new york why might that issue be
happening the people hiring are not
women and everyone that's hiring
kind of you hire who you know
and
those social circles aren't including
women so
they aren't getting hired as much
early on when i was doing a lot more
voice over i would read a lot of the
comments and the most common comment
was
i hate that girl's voice
i noticed that that comment wasn't as
common with the male vo pieces
and it's something that i know that a
lot of women in film and radio come
across i feel like women tend to be
easier targets for criticism for things
just like generally like you're not used
to having women do as much voice over
work you know we need systemic change
starting from production assistants to
associate producers to producers all the
way up hire us
that is what will make the playing field
even hire us we're here we want to be
employed we want to make films there's
so many qualified female filmmakers it's
just a matter of giving them the
opportunity i think i've been very
fortunate as a woman of color in this
industry i heard this quote once
diversity is
inviting me to the party but inclusion
is asking me to dance and that's
literally all we want is to be included
my advice to new filmmakers is to just
get out there and not
wait to start anything just just do it
just make content because you will learn
something every time you
shoot something write something edit
something what's cool about animation
and motion graphics is you can sit down
and do an entire short film just on your
own the internet is an amazing thing
it's a tool that you should definitely
take advantage of
teach yourself learn don't wait for
someone to give you an opportunity don't
wait for someone to tell you you can
believe in it because you can